but alright and we are live let's see
hello free code camp world I don't think
there's many of you guys in the comments
yet but uh hello we'll give it we'll
give you guys a few minutes to get here
and then we're gonna get started get
under way just to say it some of you
guys may not know but um the I'm
actually presenting this workshop in
front of a classroom of students part of
night club we won't work the Computer
Science Society so sometimes I'll be
talking it out that way and that'll be
to the students in the room with me and
sometimes I'll be facing the camera and
talking to you guys
so give you a few more minutes to get in
get in here and yeah we'll get underway
who in a free code camp has ever used
JavaScript before there we go I see if I
see a few people saying they have
awesome cool so to answer a question
just got this will only be covering some
es6 the goal of today's workshop is
going to be a introduction to variables
and data types in JavaScript and then
we're gonna work into using some of the
fun es6 syntax to really show off some
of the cool things you can do with
javascript and the JavaScript language
and then from there we'll talk a little
bit about some next steps some
implementation so cool I see a lot of
you guys are in here now we're gonna get
underway so if everyone can navigate
over to code pen dot IO it's the site
you see on my screen here we use this
last time in our react talk and it's
really great website I highly recommend
using this for all like learning and
even just you're building something it's
really fun it updates live for you and
it's on what you can check out other
people's fun projects as well
so to start off we're gonna create a new
pen and this time we're gonna do nothing
to the config we're gonna write strictly
JavaScript and then down in the bottom
left corner you should see the console
button I want everyone to press the
console button for me this is gonna be
where a lot of the stuff that's gonna
happen is gonna show up so we'll make
that nice and big and I'm gonna turn
over it here get my notes up and we're
gonna get started so I hope many of you
at least have a somewhat of an idea
about what um you know what JavaScript
and what coding in general is you know
we deal with data we have data in data
out we want to do stuff with that data
and the way we do that is by very most
basic concept we declare that that data
exists so in JavaScript the way we do
that it's contrary to Java or C is in
JavaScript we're gonna use the VAR
keyword that stands for variable then
we're gonna give it a name so we're
gonna say literally name equals and then
unlike most languages where you should
be declaring a datatype like a string or
an integer or a double we could just put
whatever we want to put into this
variable here and in this instance we're
gonna use a string so you can either use
a single character or you can use double
quotes and then just type your name I'm
gonna take mine another aspect to
javascript is semicolons a lot of people
are like are semicolons necessary in
JavaScript they are not I use them
because I write Java a lot as well and
it's just really easy for me to when I'm
reading my code if I can see a semicolon
I know that's the end of a line so
you'll see me using that but if you're
uncomfortable or you don't feel like
typing that extra character you don't
have to at all so we're gonna declare a
few more variables here I'm gonna say
age and then we're gonna go ahead and
I'm gonna do something fun we're gonna
say favorite bands and my favorite bands
I recently got a real friends sweater in
the mail it's a lot of
really excited to get that then we're
gonna add another one
it's called movements these bands are
really small and then one final one and
you guys can fill yours with whatever
you want you don't even have to put
bands in there you can put your favorite
ice cream flavor your favorite cookie
type your favorite pizza anything at all
and if you notice we have three
different data types here you have a
string represented in the name you have
the age which is an integer and in Java
there is no difference between declaring
integers and declaring doubles so if we
were to say fraction we can go ahead and
we can say 2.5 and that would be
essentially the same thing as writing a
double or a float in Java and then we
have a list so what's kind of cool in
JavaScript is that lists are a native
datatype their collection just like they
are in Java or Python or C and in this
collection in this list I'm using
strings but what's unique to javascript
is that you can actually put any type of
data you want inside a list with other
data types so I can actually go ahead
and put in a number here and that is
valid it's not very useful but it's very
it's it's valid and this will run just
fine
we're gonna remove that because we're
not going to do anything with it next
we're gonna go over and what an object
is so an object in JavaScript is similar
to like a class in Java but a lot more
lot basic there are classes in
JavaScript but we're not gonna go over
those because you could spend a whole
hour teaching just classes in JavaScript
but an object is declared just the same
way as these previous data types were so
I'm gonna say me because I'm the data I
have above describes Who I am and then
we're gonna use curly braces so we're
going to form this kind of code block
and then we're gonna say name or we're
gonna use string name and this is a
property then we're gonna use a colon
and then the data that that the variable
name then we do another one age the
agent
and then we're gonna say favorite bands
put the favorite bands in here and then
we're gonna use one more and we're gonna
do favorite pizza and if you notice I
haven't declared a favorite pizza the
variable yet but that's okay because I'm
going to go ahead and put the string
that describes my favorite pizza right
here and I'm just gonna say buffalo
chicken you can agree or disagree with
me on that one awesome so this is the
basics to describing variables in
JavaScript so you know there's there's
really not a whole lot to it you know
you have your list you have an object
you have doubles you have integers you
have strings and if you are wondering
how to like access this data all you do
is you know declare in our new line
we're gonna use a statement called the
console dot log statement and console
dot log is gonna let us print something
to the console which is this big grey
box to the right is so this is since
we're just gonna print out the name my
name real quick and if you notice it
pops up on the side immediately code pen
live updates as you type so sometimes
the console will get filled and I'm just
gonna clear it using the Clear button so
you'll see me do that throughout the
throughout the talk and we can go ahead
and we can change what's in here change
it to age you know 18 will appear on the
screen and then you can even plug in an
array and it'll print out the raw array
string with its um with what it's
contained with and then let's uh now
you're probably wondering great we're
storing all this data and the object
especially we have this kind of all the
data is mashed into one little object
how can we access the data in that
object we have a couple different
methods we can go ahead and we say the
object and then we can put a square
bracket and then we can put the string
of the property name inside that square
bracket like name you notice here it is
right here
here's
and then on a new I'm gonna create a new
line so you guys can keep that one there
for reference we're gonna go ahead and
we're gonna write me dot favorite pizza
if you notice down here at the bottom of
the screen buffalo chicken who was added
to the console so here are two different
ways to access very access data types on
a javascript object so how's it going
over in the free code camp side you guys
have any questions yet let's say you do
a little bit of scroll uh yeah sorry
some people are asking if a list is an
array and yes it is I'm a array list
collection those are all very synonymous
words and someone else asked let and yes
we should be using light and that's what
I was gonna get to next is that there's
these two magical words in JavaScript
that are used for variable declaration
called the Const and the let so we've
been using the ver keyword here and
you'll and what we can do with there
Lavar is you can actually reassign that
if you're not if you're using unchecked
mode so there's way you can make
JavaScript evaluate in something called
strict mode and in which case what I'm
about to do won't is not allowed but in
all intensive purposes what I am going
to do is valid in JavaScript you say var
read Eclair the name and I'm gonna say
my last name and then all of a sudden if
I was to go ahead and console dot log my
name at the bottom you'll notice at the
very bottom of the screen here the new
variable declaration for name comes up
but let's declare a let variable let
operates in much the same way as var
where you say let and then the variable
the variable name we're gonna go for
simple a and you assign it a value 1 and
this access is the same way as a
variable well you can add it to objects
but what's special about let is that
it's it's block scoped and what that
means is if you were to use this if
you're familiar with Java where your
wine you have a loop you have a for loop
we're gonna have like you know in Java
you would use like in
I well in JavaScript you would want to
use let I equals 0 I is less than you
know arbitrary number 5 I plus plus and
then we want to you know do something in
here I'm not gonna actually do anything
you know you can do something in that
code block that I variable that you've
declared in that for loop is accessible
inside here you could call I from inside
this for loop but then when you go
outside of the for loop that I variable
is no longer declared and that has to do
with the scope of the variable I don't
it's kind of confusing it's also kind of
very it's more first in tactical
purposes that difference between var and
let but just know that that's kind of
where it comes from but the third way of
declaring datatypes using the Const
keyword is the most is the most useful
one this is like declaring a final value
in Java where when you declare a
variable as a constant it cannot change
so let's go ahead and let's declare a
new one constant and B and we're going
to give it you know two very simple and
we're gonna print it out to the screen
at the bottom you should see two comes
up it does and now let's reassigned to
so say B equals three and then we're
gonna say console dot log and as long as
this doesn't fail me now it should not
get reassigned and if it does I believe
it is crashed because if you notice
nothing has reappeared underneath this
two and that is because this is invalid
if code pen doesn't show errors inside
of the console but I can what I'm
telling you right now is that this is
invalid Rheda Clara a constant is not
gonna work in any other sort of if you
were to run this in a browser console or
if you were to run this through nodejs
or some compiler like babel it will
throw an error at you and say invalid
you can tree declare a constant and it's
really again this is a the value of
having these different ways of declaring
variables is more for program structure
so program structure in a sense where if
we're writing a very complex
there's a lot of developers working on
it and we declared variable like the
database URL and we don't want that URL
to change we would declare it as a
constant that way other developers that
are using our code will know that that
database URL is never gonna change and
they can rely on that value never
changing because it's declared as a
constant
now if variable was declared as a let or
var then there would be some sort of you
know obfuscation where it could get
changed where some aspect of the code
could change that value probably in some
iterator function or the sort and then
it would be unreliable to write more
code based on that potentially changing
data type cool so that's pretty much all
I have for the variable declaration and
now we're gonna move into some of the
fun es6 stuff that we can use with these
variables before we dive straight into
that though we're gonna go over one
concept that's called functions or
methods in Java you declare a method by
writing the function keyword then the
variable then the method name you pass
it its parameters inside the parentheses
and then you add some squiggly brackets
and then inside there you can do
whatever you want with the parameters
but at the end you should return
something in our case we're gonna return
a plus B and if we go below here and we
call some there we're gonna use a
console dot log so we can actually see
it and we say sum of one comma two we
should see in our console three so magic
right I couldn't believe it myself when
I first wrote a function in JavaScript
it was that easy
so yeah that's basic basic function
syntax it's very you know very simple
but let's uh let's make this a little
bit more complicated let's um I'm gonna
show you guys a sneak peek into an array
method called map so we're first gonna
declare a constant we're gonna say
scream it
it's gonna be our it's gonna be the name
of our new array and that array is gonna
be the favorite bands dot map so in
JavaScript and in the es6 package it
sent a ton of new really useful
arraignment array methods that let you
iterate over the contents of an array
without having to use encapsulating for
loop so with what that means is you know
you pass it this method and then we can
create a function and we're gonna say
you know like we're just gonna call the
function just X because it's simple and
then we're gonna or actually we don't
need to call it anything that's my
mistake just function and then
parenthesis and then we're gonna pass it
the band parameter use the squiggly
brackets and then we will return the
band dot to uppercase and what this will
do is this map function will loop over
the entirety of the favorite bands array
and return each value fully upper case
inside a new array assigned to the
screamin variable so we can go down here
and if you and you do console dot log
and you put in scream it it should on
the side you should see all of the bands
in full upper case letters sweet so this
is very simple we're using function
notation but I want you to kind of like
look back at this we got a lot going on
here for a pretty simple task you know
we have this really long function word
that's eight it's eight bits of data
right there one byte of data is going
for just the keyword function inside our
map inside our map method and that
function keyword is almost as long as
our variable name itself so can we
reduce that we can with something called
arrow functions arrow functions is
something again new to es6 the syntax is
gonna look really weird but if you've
come from a Java background and you've
ever used a lambda expression before
it's gonna look similar to that so we're
gonna go ahead and run describe a new
very well we're call this one constant
whisper whisper it we're gonna go again
over the favorite bands all right we're
gonna map and this time instead of
writing the function keyword we're just
gonna write parenthesis just like that
and we're gonna put the band parameter
right in there and then we're going to
use equal sign greater than sign looks
like an arrow doesn't it hence why it's
called an arrow function and then you're
gonna use smoothly brackets just like we
did in the previous function and we're
gonna return the band to lowercase now
this method when we print out the result
to our to the console we should see the
bands all lowercase and if you notice
we've decreased the amount of characters
we've used in our function and that's
not all that this lets us do arrow
functions also have a really really fun
syntax we can play around with we can
actually rewrite this function that we
just wrote even more even even simpler
so I'm gonna quickly I'm gonna go ahead
and I'm gonna come I'm gonna comment
that out if you're on a Windows you can
do control forward slash while
highlighting text and it will comment
the whole block on Mac you're gonna use
command forward slash so then let's read
Eclair the whisper it alright we're
gonna say favorite bands again we're
gonna do dot map and this time we're not
gonna write parentheses we're going to
write band just the word band arrow
function and then we're gonna write band
again and then the two lowercase method
look at that one line and we got the
same behavior that we did with three
lines of code what this is doing what
this arrow function syntax is doing is
with a single oh that is pretty small
I'm sorry guys let me make that a little
bit bigger for you with that
with this single parameter datatype here
what that's letting us do is with we can
exclude the parentheses dropping the
parentheses means that this error
function is going to receive one
argument one parameter that parameter is
band then the return statement this
return statement is going to do one
thing and one thing only it's going to
return whatever comes after that arrow
function that that arrow that arrow key
right here so in this instance we're
just lower casing the entire string but
in a but in another example when I use
arrow functions and these array methods
in react in the react library I'm
writing these complex rendering
algorithms that feed in bits of data
from a database and then you surrender
like 50 different nodes that have very
similar structure very similar component
structure but change just something as
simple as the text and with react all I
do is I write an arrow function just
like this I loop over my database like
the data for my database and I just
passed it whatever's changing to my
arrow function and my arrow function is
just gonna return a piece of react
component back to the the application
and then all of a sudden I have 50 50
nodes generated from one line of code
and that's really the magic that goes
into using arrow functions and these
array methods in ESX cool so let's let's
go ahead and go over to another aspect
of es6 called default parameters and
then once we finish that I'm going to
take a quick sip of water and we're
gonna do a little bit of questions just
to make sure you guys are all caught up
so before I declared a function called
some this time I'm gonna call a function
diff and we're gonna do x and y let's
spruce it up we're gonna return the
difference of x and y and we're gonna
man here I'm gonna do console dot log
difference
of three notice anything wrong
go forth exactly
I need a y-value I've only passed one
parameter or argument to my DIF function
but it's expecting two as a result
JavaScript doesn't throw any errors all
its gonna do is return n a n which
stands for not a number and this is and
this is expected this is what JavaScript
does it tries to assume that you meant
to do this but let's say we did it we
never want to receive not a number from
our function in fact I will always want
to see a number even if that number is
wrong I still want to see a number there
so we can do is we can go inside our
function declaration and we can next to
the parameter put an equal sign and then
whatever the default value is I'm gonna
see the default value is zero now if you
notice on the right the three the the n
a n was changed to three because three
minus zero is three and then if we go
ahead and let's see what happens if we
pass no arguments the diff function it
goes back to returning nine a number and
then that a number is because the X is
not defined again we're not passing
anything in for the x value now but we
can go ahead and we can declare
something as a default for the X let's
use zero again and now if you notice
even when we call the diff function and
there's nothing passed to it we're still
gonna get a number that will keep our
application running this is really
useful for when you have some sort of
useful default data I love to go back to
react in react you have all these
components I'll have textual user
interface components you never want to
return some nasty error to your users so
instead if you could set a default like
for example a string a basic string
that's gonna be a lot more better for
your user experience than it would be
just to you know throw an error and have
the whole application crash because you
forgot to send a a parameter so cool so
I'm gonna take us a quick minute if you
guys have any questions I'd be happy to
take them at this time
no I will check the the free code camp
chat real quick let's see okay so
someone asked should one start by
learning JavaScript syntax and then es6
or right away learn es6 syntax so you
should definitely learn JavaScript first
because even though es6 is javascript
when you're writing code that good
that's gonna be used on every browser it
may not always run the es6 syntax not
yet at least
so it's best that you learn the basics
and all the very generic JavaScript
syntax first and then move on to you
know sprucing it up with some es6 plus a
lot of the es6 things that i'm gonna
show you today are quite simple but
there's just as much complicated things
that come with es6 that even i'm still
trying to you know wrap my head around
and really fully utilize in my
applications all right let's see um
another one is the rule for that syntax
that you can only do a single statement
otherwise you need to use parentheses
great question martin yes in the above
arrow function the one where we lower
case the band if we wanted to write
multiple lines here we would have to use
either those squiggly lines and a return
block or we can wrap this in parenthesis
and in those parentheses act as kind of
like a mock code block and that code
block lets it will return everything
inside of the parenthesis so let me fix
this up a little bit so what this just
did is now we can go ahead and do is now
we can actually write multiple lines but
we're gonna return everything inside it
so this gets a little weird
and if kind of again this kind of this
is this is in there mainly for react
when you're returning a JSX component
which is HTML so you know how HTML could
have multiple things within it and that
nested structure requires multiple lines
so in that instance you would use these
parentheses to return just
JSX component but that multiple line JSX
component in our example we're only
using one line of code so we're only
returning one line of code great so
we're gonna move on to another really
fun operator called the spread operator
and this is gonna replace array
concatenation so let's go ahead and
let's define another array I'm gonna
call this array more bands I like music
so I'm gonna go ahead and add a few more
in here so here's one and here's another
and now I want to make one list that
contains my more bands and my favorite
bands so let's go ahead and write let
all bands equal favorite bands dot
concat more bands and if we print that
out to the screen we should see an array
containing both the three bands that I
listed at the beginning of this talk and
the two bands I just added to it
expected and this uses a you know a
traditional JavaScript function called
concatenate and it works just like any
you know just its concatenation take
everything from one thing and you know
and everything from another object and
you smush it all together but let's say
we had a third array let's say even more
bands okay
and in this one I'm gonna write ACDC oh
that's not ac/dc and Green Day we're
gonna go ahead and we're gonna
concatenate that one now we can go ahead
and we can probably we can chain it so
we can do concat even more bands and
that just kind of looks nasty or we
could have you know we could have wrote
all bands dot can cat even more bands on
the line below it and
reassign delete that and then it should
yeah so then we can concatenate and then
see how even though we read this line we
would have to reassign the all bands
variable to this new concatenation and
look we want to concatenate all three of
these lists but right now we're using a
the concat statement over and over again
and we're read eclair in variables and
it's getting messy there's a lot of text
let's simplify this let's first of all
I'm gonna delete everything here oh
please don't go back I'm going to leave
everything here and I'm declare a newer
write a blank are right inside that
array and do three dots so and then
after those three dots we're gonna write
the name of our array that we want to
concatenate favorite bands on the right
you should see the three bands pop up
sweet then next and do comma three dots
again and then more bands if you look
over to the right the other array shows
up thank you I bet you can imagine what
we're gonna do next three dots even more
bands and now with some nice whitespace
tidying by the way javascript is a non
white space dependent code language so
you can do whatever the whatever you
want with the white space between things
javascript doesn't care because it
interprets based on keywords not based
on white space so with a nice little
syntax right like this we can keep
listing all of our arrays over and over
and over again and in a real world
example let's say we had a database with
a bunch of different lists of things I
don't know shopping carts and we wanted
to make a grand shopping cart instead of
trying to concatenate every single small
array into one big one and returning out
to the user we could build this nicely
this nice structure here with the spread
operator and spread out all the contents
into another another array this is also
useful for function declaration back up
here we had parameters right
actually if we had a array of things
let's say again a shopping cart we had
an array of we had a shopping cart full
of items and we had a function that
would I don't know make a really like a
pretty print function it would print out
all the contents in your shopping cart
and we wanted to pass every item in that
shopping cart to the function as its own
parameter not as one big list but that's
own parameter we could actually go into
the argument defining area of a function
and use the same syntax where we spread
out all the properties within an array
into some other structure like a
parameters list or an arguments list or
another array and another example react
handles state props and state that's if
you guys are interested in what I'm
talking about there is a video I did two
weeks ago around this time about react
to JavaScript and we did talk about
props and state and maintaining that and
let's say we're updating our state but
we want to hold on to all the previous
state we could actually go ahead and
let's say we had some object here right
we had like Const state equals something
and we're gonna say like list and that
list is gonna have the values 1 comma 2
in it I'm gonna I'm gonna quickly change
this to let because we're gonna re
assign this and then we want to update
this state with something new so we're
gonna stay state equals and we're gonna
say the list but then we want to
concatenate to that list so instead of
writing like list dot can cat and then
you know putting our thing in here we
could actually go ahead and we do just
put another array right like this the
spread operator on the previous list or
actually have to use state dot list and
then comma our new valuables our new our
new variables 3 4 and then all of a
sudden if we console dot log this state
you'll see we have an object with the
list one two three four and if we did
that if we did the same console dot log
statement let me put it here you see we
only have one into so you'll notice this
spread syntax is really useful for
keeping your code clean and keeping it
concise and you know letting things
maintain itself without the unnecessary
need for methods and large chains of of
methods so we can delete we can leave
that and now we're gonna go into we have
two more things to go over today
let me check some questions let's see
here um free code camp what do you
prefer jQuery or react or view I am a
react developer not only I've been
learning it for about three years now
and I have started to contribute to the
open source the open source project as
well so I like to focus on react even
though I am familiar with jQuery let's
see all right cool
so let's move on to the last two
subjects in today's workshop template
literals an object property shorthand so
we're gonna start with honestly my
favorite feature of es6 and it's called
template literals it's another way of
removing the unnecessary need to
concatenate strings so let's start off
by declaring the old way we used to
concatenate strings Const s equals and
we're gonna build a sentence here but
say my name is space plus the name
variable which we declared all the way
back at the top of this function and
we're gonna put a period in here because
you know we're writing an essay you know
we gotta make sure we have proper proper
proper sentence structure you know
console dot log put s on the right you
should see my name is arrow would name
is Ethan but that's my last name
cool and that's not too bad but what if
we want to make a more complex sentence
let's say s2 we're gonna say my name is
or actually know what to do my name is
Ethan plus
sorry plus my last name comma and I am
my age years old in the console dot log
that to the screen you'll see we get the
sentence that we want you know my name
is Ethan Arrowwood and I'm 18 years old
but that was a lot of typing and it's
really gross you know what if we want to
change the part of the sentence we got
to make sure we don't mess up you know
the spacing around the words and that
you know the name and age variable
doesn't get changed so we're gonna use
template strings so we're gonna first
gonna call a new variable constant t and
now there's a little symbol at the top
left of your keyboard next to the one
and it's a little like it's a little
tick mark it's the main it there's also
if you hold shift it would be the grave
key and it's gonna look like this and
this is template strings inside here
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
write the same sentence that we did
before we're gonna say my name is and
then instead of doing plus my the
variable name we're gonna write dollar
sign squiggly bracket it'll
automatically add another one to the end
of it and inside that just put the name
variable put your semicolon and then
console dot log the T sentence and if
you notice we get the same effect as the
the sentence structure wrote above and
this time the word is embedded directly
in here and if you wanted to add more
text to the sentence you can without any
more concatenation just comma and my
fake age is age but I actually am 18 so
let's change that let's have some fun
with this
I want to square my age in JavaScript
you weight a square numbers you use two
you use the multiplication sign the
shift eight and now and you do that
twice and you give it a number and if
you notice to the right it doubles the
age variable right in line in that and
what this does what this template letter
what these little code blocks are
doing is it's letting you embed
basically in embed JavaScript inside
your sent inside your strings so that
again when you're building these
beautiful user interfaces you wanna do
something like camelcase
a piece of text or you want to scream
something in uppercase the whole thing
but it's not stored as such you can
embed that process right into the
rendering string and it will do it right
there client-side reducing the load on a
potential server or anything you know
prior to rendering text to the screen
and this and it doesn't you know this
isn't what this is there there's so much
more you can do with this you can you
know do another we can do another
sentence and we can say my favorite band
is you'll get the same template strings
in here and we can say we have the all
bands array and we can access the first
index of that array using square
notation zero and then console dot log
the second sent the second template
shrink to the screen and all of a sudden
my favorite band is real friends very
true statement and we wrote that all in
one line we didn't have to pull off that
variable in any sort of the new
declaration we just embed it directly in
the string without the need of plus
signs or any sort of string
concatenation methods cool so there any
questions on template strings no I will
give a quick check to the chat and we'll
see alright someone's asking what are
the prerequisites for the react
framework like how much of JavaScript
etc one should need to learn before
starting react framework I can elaborate
a little bit more on this at the end but
the short answer is get down you know
the basics and then start you know be
comfortable writing some just
client-side there you know work through
the basic free code camp front-end
projects and once you finish those
front-end projects and just native
JavaScript you were more than ready to
dive right into react
and what's phenomenal is that the react
community has tons of documentation and
a lot of tutorials so it's going to be
really easy
for you to get started in the react
framework when you when you're ready and
does it have to be single quotes yes yes
mine
this tick mark is not the same as a a
normal quotation mark which is what was
kind of the st. which is on the same key
as the double quotation mark this is the
key all the way up next to the one
button so it's that it's a tick notice
how they're slightly different and
that's what is template strings they use
those special tick marks you cannot
embed this the dollar signs squiggly
bracket inside any other string cool all
right we got one more topic to go here
and then we are gonna wrap up so let's
talk about object property shorthand so
like I said at the beginning of this
workshop a lot of the things that es6
gives us is syntax that lets us simplify
how we write code it makes our lives as
developers easier so let's declare some
variables say Const lecture you wanna
say algorithms and then we're gonna say
Const capacity equals 20 students or say
Const professor because I don't want to
give out anyone names I'm gonna say
professor arrow would you know someday
and then we're gonna say Conte and then
we're going to go ahead and we're in
declare a classroom in this classroom
object traditionally what we wrote to be
very beginning we wouldn't have to you
know use a string lecture and then we'd
have to put the lecture variable here
and then we'd go to the next line and
write capacity and so on and so forth
and that would get to excuse me that
would get tedious what we can do instead
so we can actually go ahead and delete
everything aside from the word lecture
don't even don't even wrap it in strings
just the word lecture same for capacity
and same for professor if we come down
here and we print the classroom object
you'll notice that all of our variables
all of our data that we predefined is
input directly into our object and it
can be used the same way as any other
object is you can reference it you can
pull it out you could save things to it
and this is just a nice really useful
way to to declare objects in a very
simple format however let's say you
wanted to call you know what say you
wanted to be a little bit more strict
with your object definition you wanted
to call the professor
you know property the full string so you
know you want to add the rest of the
word professor now this is not gonna
render anything on the console here
because this is actually breaking this
is code this is going undefined there is
no variable type called professor so in
this instance we would still need to use
the you know assignment operator colon
and then the variable professor or prof
PRF and then it happens again so this is
just and then what this lets you do is
that as your object grows you add more
properties let's say building and we say
you know Wentworth we can go ahead and
we can just you know add that property
straight to our object and it just
appears and it imports whatever string
or any data you pass to it and this is
not discriminant to just strings and
integers you can actually go ahead and
in the instance there are multiple
buildings you could you know pass in an
array of like of buildings here and you
would get a list and it would work the
same way so this is just an example and
then what this leads to and you're like
why is this really that useful well it's
it has to do with it's it's all it all
goes back to react for me at least where
you have these long complex rendering
algorithms with a lot of JSX and for
those that don't know JSX is HTML
written in javascript and you want to
embed things you want to pass properties
and tons of data to these HTML blocks
but you don't want to like write out
these super long pieces of code that are
impossible to read so instead you will
pass it just a basic object with the
property that has the same name as the
value or data that it's representing and
that just keeps cleaner code for you
know easier readability and ease or
usability down the down the road as a
special treat I do have one last thing I
just forgot to put it in the description
of the livestream and the description
for the email blast and this is
destructuring
I use this a lot in the react workshop
two weeks ago and this lets us pull
things off of objects so let's quickly
create a new object will keep this one
simple just a we're gonna say a B C B C
D F or whatever C D F and then we go
down here and we're gonna say I want to
read the values from this object but I
don't want to have to declare you know I
want have to be like Const a equals X
dot a and then you know Const B equals X
dot B this is this is valid this is very
this is the way you should use what you
could do it but there's a different way
if your variable name is the same as the
property name in the object you can
actually simplify this to Const squiggly
brackets a comma B equals x then we
delete the code above that and then we
can go ahead and let's use our template
strings you know let's print out the a
variable and the B variable and if
everything is correct we should see the
string on the right unless I did
something wrong
well so I save hmm well that was
supposed to work but it's not so I guess
if anyone can tell me what's wrong
otherwise that is something I'm not
familiar with well I guess that's okay
there are ways to diiie structure and I
have you I did use them in the react
talk it's not working right now and
that's my mistake but at this moment I'd
like to open the floor to any questions
from you guys that's pretty much all I
have for you than anyone in the YouTube
chat if you guys have any questions I'd
love to answer that as well anyone in
the room no all right let's see the chat
let's see what we got here
um how do you put an apostrophe inside a
template string good question
you can use um you know you can just use
an escape character if you had a Const
t3 and you had the asterisks and you
said like I don't know like Ethan
Ethan's like Ethan's item then you could
input that character into the string
directly like that using a backspace
character yes
jo W in the chat brings up a good point
ES 6 needs transpiling um
code pen lets you run ESX directly
google chrome lets you run ESX directly
and they believe firefox now let's your
nes 6 directly and I'm not sure about
Internet X I'm the internet explorer for
example does not the old not Microsoft
edge but Internet Explorer which some
people still do use on old operating
systems does not let you run es6 code so
what you need to do is you need to use
something like
which we used in the react talk and we
transpile it back down to you know yes
you know javascript native code so we
can actually go to the babel compiler
and we can actually you know put some
code into it they have their live thing
here though their rep Apple though this
is from the last one so you see that a
little bit of JavaScript here here's an
a so here's an example of working
destructuring notice how we're pulling
the club the club variable off the props
object and the props object is being
passed to the greeting function so and
then also look here's another error
function so you can see here in react
code me using a lot of the features that
I told you guys today and I even have a
default parameter inside my
destructuring so a lot of this stuff
really is combined together but what I
wanted to show you is that we can go see
we can go consti equals and we can use a
actually a let's do this constant equals
1 and then consti 2 equals template
string i have 1 or tea cookies and then
on the right you should see that in
native javascript you're going to have
you know variable t equals 1 and then
variable t 2 equals I have plus T plus
cookies so this is you know what I'm
showing you guys you're simplifying the
way you need to write code what's up
in different blocks yeah so as long so a
constant is blocks go everything is you
know top-down scoped so if you declare a
constant up here unlike the global and
then you created a code block and this
is actually syntactically valid I didn't
know that for a while
but this is actually syntactically valid
you create a code block on the page and
you were to reference the you know
console dot log T that's valid or yes
you know it'll do it and if you wanted
to read a Claire that variable T inside
here technically you could but you
really shouldn't the reason like I
actually I'm sorry this is not allowed
if you have the let keyword this would
be allowed but why don't you see on the
screen right here is not valid this will
run an error because the T the constant
T on the outside of our block scope is
feeding itself into thus the local block
scope but if you do the reverse and you
had like constant T declared in here and
you know I'm just gonna delete this top
and we had our local block here and then
we had another constant T out here then
this doesn't work either in your like
but why not it's because JavaScript when
it reads a whole file all the constants
get lifted to the top of the file and
then fed back down so then what you just
lets you do if I remember correctly is
you're actually able to go ahead and you
know write a console dot log statement
and you can log a variable before it was
the client before it was defined and
that's technically valid it's really bad
coding but technically it's allowed
let's look at some more questions in
here alright um cool so yeah I don't
think we have anything left in the chat
someone quickly asked why do we use
bable bable is just a transpiler it lets
you take es6 code and put it into native
JavaScript use what you would need to
use if you're going to deploy your
application across
multiple browsers but if you're running
something inside no js' console or
you're writing something inside code pen
or you're running something inside of a
Google Chrome console you don't need to
use Babel because it es6 is valid syntax
but with that that is all I have for
today guys thank you so much on the free
code camp and for joining me I hope you
guys had a lot of fun you guys can watch
the video you can also reach out to me
at my Twitter I'll post that in the chat
at any time I'd be happy to take your
questions there and you can also find me
on github at ethan - Arrowwood and again
you guys can reach out to me on github
or twitter I'd be happy to teach you
some things about open-source talk to
you about react or talked about
JavaScript so I hope everyone the free
code camp end has a wonderful day
and yeah thank you for tuning in and
thank all you guys for being here in
person that was incredible
thank you very much oh sweet